[Musique]
max orville bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes candidat à schoelcher vous êtes
conseiller municipal de l'opposition
vous êtes également président du modem
martinique et vous êtes directeur
d'école et vous avez décidé de faire une
liste commune avec daniel chômé tout à
fait et bien parce que nous avons estimé
que l'union faisait la force nous
n'allions quand même pas être assez
irresponsable et de faire de multiplier
le nombre de listes d'opposition face à
un maire il était bon lorsque nous avons
le même constat et les mêmes
perspectives pour la ville donc de nous
réunir que ce qui qui mme sylla c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose qui
mènera la liste est bien au jour
d'aujourd'hui la proposition que le
modem martinique et son président en
l'occurrence moi même la proposition que
nous allons faire sera de
demandé à daniel chomet de conduire
cette liste commune car d'une part c'est
une personne d'expérience c'est
quelqu'un qui a été président de bassin
qui a été président de la première
agence de l'énergie qui a dirigé le parc
régional qui est un homme politique
connu reconnu et en plus compétences ce
qui n'est pas un luxe c'est à dire qui a
l'expérience à notre avis pour pouvoir
conduire cette liste commune qu'est-ce
qui vous unit avec daniel chômé quels
sont les points de convergence de la
chase cher de faire de gagner la ville
quels sont les points de convergence
mais justement c'est la ville de
schoelcher qui nous unit c'est celle
cher d'abord nous avons des parcours
différents mais nous partageons des
valeurs communes
nous avons des prises des principes
communs et des perspectives pour la
ville que nous partageons en termes
d'éducation terme de transition
écologique en transition énergétique ce
qui est effectivement une de ses
compétences majeures et nous avons donc
encore une fois décidé de travailler
ensemble pour ces raisons d'accord vous
avez donc choisi daniel chomet pourquoi
pas vous ce que vous êtes déjà vous
conseil municipal tout à fait mais là
encore il faut savoir rassembler daniel
chaume et moi même nous avons été nous
avons rencontré les autres candidats de
l'opposition
nous avons eu des réunions communes et
nous avons rencontré marine et de
torpilles également bien sûr nous avons
contrés marinette tant pis nous avons
contrés aussi franck sainte-rose
heureusement nous avons dit très
clairement lors de ces réunions que nous
n'étions pas fermé que nous ne faisions
pas de la tête de liste un préalable
donc difficile de faire plus large pour
essayer de rassembler bon et bien
seul daniel chow mais parce que j'ai été
sollicité également de manière
personnelle par les autres candidats
et j'ai estimé que pour travailler avec
les uns et les autres il ne fallait pas
au départ commencer par exclure donc si
tout le monde est venu me chercher pour
me dire oui on veut travailler avec toi
peut-être que on voulait exclure un ou
une des candidates donc en l'occurrence
- j'ai estimé qu'aujourd'hui pour gagner
celle cher il faut se rassembler et il
faut faire le plus large rassemblement
et sortir de nos petits ego et de nos
petits calculs donc avec daniel chow
mais nous avons eu un accord total tant
sur le constat que sur le projet qu
est-ce que ce cet accord ce qui est une
possibilité d'ouverture vers d'autres
candidats tout à fait tout à fait ya
cette possibilité d'ouverture mais si
possible bien avant le premier tour il
n'est pas question de reproduire ce que
nous avions vu en 2015 à la ctm c'est à
dire dans la chaleur comme jeudi de la
nuit de négocier et de trouver des
accords qu'on n'avait jamais pu trouver
avant chaque jour ou plus transparent
c'est beaucoup plus clair c'est beaucoup
plus nette pour les lecteurs et pour le
citoyen alors vous dites que celle cher
a perdu de son dynamisme
c'est une ville qui pour vous on rome
oui exactement c'est la vérité celle
cher à une vocation à pouvoir
comment dirais-je a des atouts et des
dés les compétences pour pouvoir
entraîner pour pouvoir être dynamique
avant hier il ya plus de douze ans était
madiana c'était les places de schoelcher
qui faisait l'admiration de tout citoyen
martiniquais aujourd'hui on répare les
voirie les trottoirs certes nécessaire
mais un petit peu d'ambition ne ferait
pas de mal max orville je vous remercie
c'est moins